Senate committee now hear from Jacob
Lawson climate is s chief coordinator
may the record reflect that he was
nearly one hour late yeah sorry about
that I literally had to fly in from
outer space thanks Justin of satellite
natural disasters have become a thing of
the past we can control our weather mr.
president one of our thermosphere it
satellites malfunction two over
Afghanistan so your proposal is what you
should sound all satellite I don't need
to remind all of you how many people
died from catastrophic climate
conditions which goes no further with us
are you going back up straight coming
back I promise
have a big trip sir just don't touch
anything
this is a gloss 3j glosses you look much
older than I would have caught I mean
true good I give you player my access
has been blocked so that I heard the bad
comm that happen what is no friction it
was intentional this potential for
catastrophic weather events on a global
scale a Geo storm
we have to shut the system down
the only one who has the kill coats is
the president and in your health your
soliciting Secret Service agent
seriously we're kidnapping the president
in a self-driving cat Jake you can't
stop it no I
[Music]
you realize you're committing treason oh
yeah I kidnap the president I just own
States dignity yeah I don't think I'm
forgetting honey honey
[Music]
how is it
you